>>Scott Draves: Hello everybody. Good evening.
Thanks for coming tonight. Welcome to Digital
Art at Google's Lecture Series. This is our
second show. We write this to you from the
distant future cospired, co-sponsored by the
Chelsea Art Museum.
My name is Scott Draves and I'll be the MC
for tonight, and I'm standing in for Josh
Mittleman who's really the-the Google engineer
who initiated this project and unfortunately
he-he can't be here tonight and he sends his-his
regrets.
But Google's mission is to organize the world's
information and make it accessible, and art
is one way of accessing or understanding information.
And so we thought since our office here is
in New York and-and in Chelsea and our-our
and because of our-our, we thought that it
would be great to get so, to reach out to
the art world and work together. And so that's
how and so Josh contacted Nina Colosi who
curated these shows and brought us the wonderful
artists who we're going to hear here tonight.
So first we have James Tunick and later Jack
Toolin will be speaking.
So James is an artist focused on the intersection
of creativity and technology in public spaces,
an entrepreneur, and software developer. He
lives and works in New York City where he
founded StudioIMC.
His work has been featured at ARS Electronica,
the USF Contemporary Art Museum, Rolling Stone
Magazine, the Museum of Modern Art, the New
York Times, and many venues and-and media
outlets.
He has two patents pending on software that
allows large audience participation with games,
ads, and digital art on billboards and video
screens in Times Square, major league baseball
stadiums, and the like.
Tunick co-founded Mapcidy, a social platform
that uses Google Earth and Web5design, a Web
development firm. He's been a very busy guy.
Tunick received his B.A. from Yale University
and his Master's from the NYU Tisch Interactive
Telecommunications Program, ITP.
So take it away James. Thank you very much.
[applause]
>>James Tunick: [unintelligible] that introduction.
So first I wanna start with a little bit of
personal background and then talk a little
bit more about professional background.
I'm gonna skip through the-the bio that Scott
mostly just read and kind of try and boil
that down into a few key points.
Who am I? I am yet an artist, a software developer,
and an entrepreneur. My focuses are really
at the intersection of art technology and
gaming in public spaces.
My work appears on the Web, mobile devices,
and also in public spaces on big screens.
And the reasons I do these things and-and
the things that-that really drive me are my
passion and-and wanting to really encourage
creativity in public spaces, empowering people
to express themselves in public spaces, and
enhancing future cities using technology and
art as a way to make our cities more livable.
I feel very strongly and-and I'm really very
passionate about this-this idea that actually
has been around for-for some time since the
'60s and Rauschenberg's work and E.A.T., Experiments
in Art and Technology at the Armory here in
New York.
And really feel strongly that the intersection
of technology and art, especially in public
spaces, has the power to inspire a sense of
magic. It allows us to strengthen communication
in communities. It allows people to become
artists in public spaces. It puts the-the
power into the hands of people in cities for
each to express themselves on the sides of
buildings and elsewhere. It has the power
to stimulate community collaboration in like
free speech and public discourse.
Of course these are all idealistic ways of-of
looking at these things. I think that technology
in public spaces is a doubled-edged sword
and it can also be used for-for bad things.
But we're starting to see new forms of storytelling,
new forms of gaming, technology and art that
provides easier access to information and
entertainment in public spaces. And increasingly
this is becoming known as the Outernet. In-in
the industry it's called Digital Out-of-Home
and usually refers to advertising, but my
focus is-is both in the arts, entertainment,
as well as in advertising.
So if you can imagine a-a city of the future
where the city becomes even more of a cultural
hub than it already is, where buildings become
canvases and cell phones become paint brushes;
where every person has the power to express
themselves on the side of a building or play
a large audience game.
I'm gonna walk through some of my early art
works. I'm gonna try and actually go through
the presentation rather quickly so that I
can show videos and live demos of some of
these art works.
One of the first works that I consider important
is a 9/11 memorial sculpture called "WHY"
that I built at Yale University. It was essentially
two planks of wood, a bunch of magic markers,
and a plaque that asks people to express themselves
and-and answer the question, "Why?" in regards
to 9/11.
And within days it was absolutely covered
in writing and diagrams and people discussing
the topic with each other, comments connected
with lines and drawings and pictures, and
I mean everything under the sun in terms of
opinions and-and the ways that people are
expressing themselves about these-these sad
events.
From there at ITP, the Interactive Telecommunications
Program at NYU, I began to think more about
free speech in public spaces and-and how to
leverage technology as a way to allow people
to-to express themselves more easily.
Traded a work called The Free Speech Bulletin
which was fairly basic installation that allowed
people to send text messages to a mobile projection.
So there was a boat battery, there was a screen
on wheels, we would project on buildings or
on the screen on wheels, and allowed people
to answer questions about politics, local
community, and essentially allowed people
to express themselves and-and their opinions.
From there I created a-a work with another
artist named Miro Kirov, who was a classmate
at ITP. This is a work called "Infinite City,"
where using gesture people can fly through
a 3D cityscape and also compose music in real
time. So it was a multi-user, immersive environment
that allowed people to express themselves
through music and kind of fly through this
futuristic cityscape.
You'll see there are some common themes in
terms of this idea of the future city and
I'll talk a little bit more specifically about
City of the Future which is the-the work outside
that I've got installed with my wife, Carrie
Elston Tunick and another colleague, Josh
Schiller.
Next early work is-is a piece of technology
called the "Media Bandit" and you'll see that
a lot of my work kinda bridges commercial
and art world. I consider on the art side
this is a type of kind of media pop art. At
the same time many of the art works that-that
I've created with-with colleagues and others
at StudioIMC have been used commercially by
clients like Heineken and others.
So this was essentially a portable VJ station
that people could take out to events. Started
actually my career in-in doing live video
mixing and VJ work in night clubs and restaurants
as-as a teenager and so became very interested
in this idea of kind of putting the audience
into the visuals at these events and essentially
created a piece of software that allowed live
video mixing, live video to be mixed in with
some of the logos.
This is another early work called "Cell Sketch"
and I'll demo this a little bit later as well.
This is a work that allows people to sketch
with the light from their cell phone. So standing
in front of the screen you can draw a smiley
face, you can spell your name, and essentially
the-the phone becomes a paint brush. It also
generates sound when you move your phone and
so there's this kind of connection between
you and-and the screen both visually and in
terms of the music.
Another early work that's related to "Infinite
City," this is a work called "Collaborative
Immersive Networked Environment" or CINE.
This was another immersive environment that,
it was kind of a vision of-of future cities
that allowed people to send pictures from
city streets and then those pictures would
show up in a 3D city and it was a multi-user
environment; multiple people could control
it and-and fly through the space. I'll show
a video of this as well later on. And then
the pictures could actually be posted as billboards
on any of the virtual buildings.
The idea was kind of this mixture of virtual
and real and also, so it was part of my research
at-at ITP and kinda getting towards this idea
of the multi-user computer interface environment.
The mouse and keyboard is-is rather restrictive
when it comes to navigating the Web, making
music, and so this was really an attempt at
kind of experimenting with a multi-user interface,
putting the computer into the space, tracking
hand movement and body movement, and allowing
people to fly through this 3D city.
I just mention this-this work briefly. This
is a-a white paper and-and actually a paper
that was selected as a finalist in a design
competition at Data Play Social Evolutions
Conference and really was kind of the first
time that I began to think about this idea
of blending cell phone displays and social
software in-in public spaces. This idea has
evolved some since, but really convinced that
we're gonna see the Internet evolve into the
Outernet.
There will be in public spaces a merging of
mobile devices, big screens, media facades,
and architecture, as well as the Web. Social
talk where as-as we know it today is-is still
fairly basic and I think that in the future
we will see in public spaces how these can
add up and become more than the sum of their
parts.
Another early work that I built with my wife
and-and another colleague, Aaron Schiller.
This is called "Park of the Future." This
was featured in the L.A. Times and really
is kind of the first inkling of-of the next
work I'll talk about [unintelligible.
[pause]
The work is-is really a-a concept that ties
into many of the things I've already mentioned:
media facades, reskinable buildings, promoting
free speech through text messaging, picture
messaging and really trying to encourage public
discourse in neighborhoods and city parks.
[pause]
This is a more recent work. This is a stereoscopic
3D environment called "Parallel Cityscapes"
that was at the USF Contemporary Art Museum.
You would put on stereo glasses which you
now see in-in a lot of movie theaters, similar
type of 3D where it pops out of the screen.
And this was actually the first time that
I showed what's called the IMC-Space which
I'll talk about a little bit later on. Essentially
a 3D visualization of YouTube videos and other
data feeds where the user can fly through
an immersive space and kind of see the universe
of data related to certain YouTube users or
other large data sets.
Another recent work called "Circuit." This
is a video art work that was shown by Nina
and-and Streaming Museum on billboards around
the world. Another information, visualization,
3D space that takes Twitter feeds and puts
them into a 3D environment that you can fly
through.
And this is the work that's on display at
ARS Electronica right now and-and here in
the lobby at-at Google. And actually this
will probably be better explained by the video
later on so I'm going to continue to kind
of push through the presentation here and
go into more detail in a bit.
So those are kind of my personal artworks.
I also as-as Scott mentioned founded a-a company
out of college called StudioIMC. We are essentially
a collective of programmers and artists. We
do work both commercially and in the arts.
All of our programmers are also artists and
we represent them in that we put them into
art shows at museums and galleries and curate
these shows at-at museums and galleries.
So this is one of the first shows that we
did called "Convergence" which was about the
mixture of virtual and real.
Another StudioIMC art show, a three month
show at the Museum of TV and Radio which is
now called the-the Paley Center for Media,
which was trying to imagine future forms of
entertainment. It was called "Beyond TV" and-and
it was again focused on media artists from
StudioIMC.
Second IMC exposition. This is a trade show
and art show that StudioIMC puts on about
every two years. It started out as an annual
show, but became a larger production than-than
expected and this is the second expo which
involved holographic light sculptures, interactive
installations, and a variety of other types
of works.
This is the more recent IMC exposition. I
think the catalogues may have been passed
around and will give you kind of a, I think
a good idea of how we bridge the art world
and-and the commercial world, big screens
and public spaces. We were lucky enough to
have Daktronics as a partner, Streaming Musueum
as a partner.
Daktronics is the-the largest maker of billboards
in the world and they're in baseball stadiums.
And in addition we also showed many of the
works by StudioIMC artists, emerging artists
from ITP, and all of them with a focus on
promoting collaboration, public spaces, allowing
people to participate in the artworks either
through phone, through gesture, through voice
control.
So this leads into some of my more commercial
work, but I think that-that-the two are really
interjoined.
StudioIMC is-is a new media lab here in New
York City. We build software for the Outernet
producing games and-and art and interactive
ads for big screens in public spaces.
As I mentioned before we also represent an
international team, whoops, sorry 'bout that.
[unintelligible]
[pause]
We also represent an international team of
artists and programmers, many of them from
ITP, some of them colleagues from Yale, others
met over the years in-in Europe and in Asia,
and we show their work again in-in museums
and at the StudioIMC lab and gallery here
in New York.
Our approach is to develop creative software
tools that inspire a sense of magic and invite
collaboration in public spaces through interactivity,
engagement, and measurement.
Short list of-of some of our clients.
We produce three technologies for big screens.
Again can push digital art, they can push
ads, new types of entertainment and gaming
to big screens and to phones.
Two of the software platforms have patents
pending.
The software powers the world's first network
of interactive movie screens. So before the
movies start people can pull out their phones
or wave at the screen to play a game or interact
in some way.
In stadiums, at concerts, on video walls and
building lobbies and the platform is really
I think all of this kind of ties back to our
early work in-in video art, VJing and-and
pushing digital art in public spaces.
This is a platform that works on screens of
any size and it allows people to interact
through one of three ways. And first way is
through cell phone interaction, so it's either
through texting or sending pictures or actually
calling into a number and then the phone becomes
a joy stick for the screen and you can have
hundreds or even thousands of people playing
at once.
Gesture interaction. So we, part of my background
at-at Yale and ITP was in computer vision
and-and face tracking and so we allow audience
members to essentially play the game or-or
interact with the artwork using hand gestures,
using face movement, body movement. And then
voice interaction is the third type of interactivity.
These can be blended, "City of the Future"
out in the lobby actually uses both cell phone
interaction and gesture interaction.
The platform works with multiple modules,
multiple pieces of interactive content. Essentially
we have about a hundred of these modules.
Some of them are digital artworks, some of
them are advertisements, some of them are
games.
And this is the software being used in-in
Times Square currently by Sony and-and News
Corp at One Times Square where people can
send votes and it shows up on the screen in-in
real time.
Houston Astros are using the software to allow
fans to send pictures of their kids up to
the screen, send chat messages, and also to
vote for their favorite players.
Dallas Mavericks have been using it for similar
purposes.
These are two large audience games in movie
theaters that we built recently. One is for
Sprint and the one in the upper left is for
Benihana Restaurants.
The Benihana game -- the audience could put
their hands up and essentially help a chef
catch shrimp in his hat. So moving left and
right, the hat would move left and right with
the audience and basically a large audience
game. People are jumping out of their seats
and screaming and yelling and trying to take
control of the chef's hat.
The game on the right you would call into
a phone number, hundreds of people can play
at once, you hop out of a limo, you dodge
paparazzi, and you make your way to the movie
premier.
More basic types of interactivity in movie
theaters with voting.
Some big audience games for film studios.
I'll kind of zip through some of the rest
of this so we have time for some of the videos
and-and live demos.
This a technology I mentioned earlier where
the phone actually becomes a game controller.
This is for Diageo.
Heineken augmented reality; this is something
called "Magic Mirror" that was on display
at the Time Warner Center.
IMCtv's been used for digital art at the IAC
Building. They claim to have the largest HD
video wall in the world. I think it's over
120 feet long and we created three custom
modules for those screens.
Video walls for the Nets in Times Square.
Immersive environments for National Amusements
where there was digital art and movie trailers
on all the screens.
We've also done some R & D with artificially
intelligent characters and-and holograms that
will respond to speech and movement.
Skip through some of this.
This is our mobile platform.
We've also developed a technology that allows
both in-in the arts and commercially signage
owners and building owners to track how many
people have looked at the display. It doesn't
know who you are, doesn't record video. Think
of this as click tracking for public spaces.
[pause]
This is the final piece of technology I'm-I-m
gonna talk about before heading into the videos.
This is a piece of technology called "IMCspace"
which is essentially a visualization of large
data sets; so whether it plugs into YouTube
or Flicker.
What it does is that it provides a bird's
eye view of large data sets. So the taller
the buildings, the more views the YouTube
video has gotten.
Clusters are users and the clusters next to
them are their friends. So if you're looking
for a very specific video, of course you can
use standard Google search and it sends you
directly to the video.
If you wanna see the universe of videos around
the user and get an idea of kind of the bird's
eye view of that data set, this is essentially
a way of-of doing so. So this is a fly through
3D space that has been in artworks and-and
we have not used it commercially in any way,
but our hope is that this is potentially a
way of visualizing large data sets on the
Web in the future.
So I really feel very strongly that with the
video game generation growing up and with
people living in a 3D environment, that the
Web will soon become an immersive 3D space
that you can fly through. There will still
be a use for the flat page for reading, for
searching for a single thing, but the-the
magic, the-the immersive experience of flying
through a large data set I think is-is bound
to take over.
Of course there have since the '70s and '80s
been people talking about virtual reality
and the hopes for 3D and it's kind of flopped
and flopped time and time again.
But I think that inevitably the fact that
we think in 3D, that our memory's, our memory's
actually much stronger in-in terms of a spatial
memory. You think about how many items can
you remember in your home folder on your computer?
Maybe five, maybe ten. How many items can
you remember in your home? The soap dish,
the clock, the lamp on the bedside table.
Your spatial memory is much stronger than
trying to remember a list or-or a bunch of
names. So I think that's fairly inevitable
at-at some point.
My hope is that the computer of the future
will not be this tiny thing that one person
sits in front of, but it becomes an environment
and of course the "City of the Future" is
a place where people can play games, paint
on the side of buildings, and-and the like.
So I'm going to quickly show a video of the
"City of the Future" which is the artwork
out here in-in the lobby. I'm gonna skip I
think some of the others.
[pause]
[clicking sound]
[techno playing in background]
>>Narrator: City of the Future. Concept. Free
speech in the environment.
Imagine a new type of ubiquitous communication
medium that builds community and encourages
creativity by making culture visible in public
spaces.
Envision a city that is constantly interacting
with and aware of its natural environment.
Buildings and networked objects built with
green materials display key info about their
surroundings, such as local pollution levels,
energy consumption, or recycling habits.
One day we will see each other and see our
environment in brand new ways.
It is our hope to create a model showing that
cities one day become smart spaces and large
scale augmented environments with embedded
technologies that promote free speech, green
thinking, and creative innovation.
Cities will be more transparent and democratic;
buildings and parks filling with people's
ideas and artworks.
Our method is to offer an open source model
or open blueprint for future urban architecture
in public spaces that combine green architecture,
smart spaces, ambient displays, immersive
environments, mobile devices, and networked
objects.
Our goal is to encourage free speech, community
innovation, and sustainability for future
generations.
Phase one of the project consists of responsive
architecture in outdoor immersive environments.
Such environments and architecture act actually
as we use is types of skins. Think of it as
a replaceable desktop.
Each building would have its own look and
feel that could change day to day: one moment
a-an ocean landscape, in another moment a
rain forest. Projections on the sides of the
buildings means that the architecture becomes
totally malleable. In a way it can be totally
changeable: changing the sense of space.
The second phase of the project is about community
collaboration where we would use ambient architectural
displays location specific environment data.
For example, the environmental light sculpture
actually shows how bad global warming has
gotten. So this can be a monument in the middle
of a city, a large sculpture in a city park,
and powered by solar panels.
In addition, there are also location specific
environmental data displays on buildings that
show local energy consumption levels and recycling.
Another type of light sculpture using wireless
technologies might be a pollution meter showing
people how bad pollution is
in a certain part of the city.
The third part of the project is creative
culture and using free speech spaces and community
bulletin boards people would be encouraged
to create and-and participate in local politics,
play big games, see tourist maps, participate
in culture and entertainment, send comments
to bulletins in-in parks, trading videos,
sending text messages about local issues.
And the fact is this can be something outdoors,
this can be something indoors, like the media
immersion room seen here, where people essentially
are-are able to use the space as-as a place
for collaboration, as a place for free expression.
As a whole, using smart architecture and wireless
technologies, it's our hope to offer this
open source model that will actually build
stronger communities.
The city will come alive. At one moment a
rain forest, the next moment teeming with
user generated videos, and comments and cell
phones on issues like the status of the local
school system.
The city will be an open candidate for expression,
responding to our every need and allowing
urban dwellers to communicate on a higher
level.
Such an urban society would not only be more
beautiful but would also promote creativity,
justice, accountability, and a closer, more
transparent community.
[techno music playing]
>>James Tunick: You'll have to excuse the
poor sound and-and rough graphics. This video's
actually about three or four years old at
this point. And I think that that's probably
about all the time I-I have here.
I wanted to show one last item if I have 10
seconds.
>>Scott: Sure.
>>James Tunick: This is actually the artwork
that's on display out-out front and actually
I'll turn the video tracking on.
This is pulling YouTube videos live from the
Web and again the taller the video the more
views it's gotten.
Each cluster is a user so this is [lonelygirl15]
and her friends. And again the idea is that
you can kind of get an idea of the universe
of-of videos around this user and her friends.
I'm able to navigate the space using the light
from my phone. This is true on the installation
outside.
And anyway this is an example of-of the types
of-of work that I'm doing and is being done
by other artists at StudioIMC.
And that said if you'd like to see the presentation,
other demos, a lot of this'll be available
at studioimc.com/google.
[pause]
>>Scott Draves: Thank you very much.
>>James Tunick: Thank you.
[applause]
Scott Draves: We have a couple minutes for
questions if-if anybody has something they
wanna ask James.
[pause]
>>male in audience: [unintelligible] to the
readability and accessibility [unintelligible]
>>James Tunick: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Scott Draves: Please repeat the question
so that --
>>James Tunick: Yeah.
>>Scott Draves: for the recording.
>>James Tunick: So the question was: have
I thought about readability and accessibility
in terms of putting large data sets in-in
public spaces, correct?
>>male in audience: Yes.
>>James Tunick: So text in a 3D space is a
particular challenge. People are used to looking
for labels and tags when it comes to, especially
user generated content. I think, however,
that the ability first of all to zoom in and
see some of this text and also to be able
to, from the bird's eye view, get visual cues
about the information without the use of text,
allows the information potentially to be more
accessible.
So from pulling back and-and kind of once
you understand of course there's a key for-for
many of these visualizations that'll tell
you x axis is the user, the y axis is the
number of views that the video has gotten,
the z axis is another parameter, that once
people understand that key information will
become more accessible.
Also if there are visual cues as to what things
mean it can be more intuitive. I think Brad
W. Paley spoke a little bit about that in-in
his talk in terms of using iconic imagery
and-and visual cues that allow you to kind
of immediately understand what the information
visualization means.
Scott Draves: We have time for one more question.
>>male in audience: Yes, you made a couple
of references to holograms --
>>James Tunick: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: is that literally true,
I mean did, are you literally producing holograms?
>>James Tunick: There are a couple different
types of holographic display technologies
that we've been working with. Most of our
focus is on the software side.
But we work with artists that build LED structures,
sculptures that will have volumetric imagines
floating inside of them so you can't pass
your hand through it, but it is volumetric
holographic image.
We've also worked with a variety of different
semi-transparent materials that you can project
through from multiple angles and create a
holographic effect as well.
[pause]
>>Scott Draves: Thank you very much.
And now we'll have Jack Toolin.
[pause]
So Jack is an interdisciplinary artist whose
work spans photography, performance art, and
new media.
His work has been exhibited nationally and
internationally at venues such as the Whitney
Musuem of American Art, the San Jose Museum
of Art, the Museo Nacional de Bellas Artes
Buenos, in Buenos Aires, Argentina, and ARS
Electronica in Linz, Austria.
He is visiting assistant professor at Pratt
Institute, an adjunct professor at Polytechnic
Institute at NYU.
Are you ready to go?
[pause]
>>Jack Toolin: Yes.
>>Scott Draves: Okay.
[pause]
>>Jack Toolin: Is it on?
>>Scott Draves: Yeah.
[sound of microphone scraping]
>>Jack Toolin: Thanks.
Okay, thanks Chris.
[pause]
Okay.
Great.
Thanks for coming. Thanks for being here.
Thanks to Nina for-for putting this together
and thanks to Google, Scott and Andrew for
inviting me to talk.
So I'm gonna focus on a project that is a
complex project and multi-dimensional, but
I do wanna give you a little bit of background
about myself and where the project comes from.
My name is Jack and for 10 years I was a collaborator
in a group called C5 and we were based in
Silicon Valley. We got together in '97 and
collaborated 'til 2007 working on a range
of projects, but they were all about technology,
culture, art, and theory.
And as you can see in my little blurb up there,
our motto was: "Theory as Product." So the
projects that we would work on were largely
driven by reading and thinking we were doing
regarding technology and its effect on culture.
This list of people are my collaborators there
for this project that I'm going to focus on.
It's called the "Landscape Initiative."
But to give you just a little bit of background
on the group and where we were coming from.
As I said we got together in '97 and being
in the Silicon Valley we were kind of caught
up in the whole dot com rush and producing
work that was really screen-based early on
doing data visualization work like the image
that you see at the –
[sound of drill running]
top there is actually of a page of linkable
colors that take you to hosted Websites in
the database that we accumulated with a crawler
that would go out and ping potential URL's
and record URL's that were hosted.
It was an alternate way of surfing the Web
in a sense and because of the way the-the
octets or the IP addresses are arranged on
the screen, it in a sense gave you a portrait
of Web space.
And I can tell more about that piece or anything
I'm talking about, I'm just kind of skimming
through this just to give you a background.
So this is a-a screen-based piece, it's so
called net-art.
The piece over on the right with the green
that was a piece of software that we wrote
that you could download to your computer and
it would scan your hard drive and kind of
examine the way you work with information:
how many folders you create; how many folders
within folders you make; and what the size
of the documents are within those folders.
It wouldn't tell you anything more specific
than that but that information alone can tell
a lot about the way a person works with information
and what kinds of information you're working
with. The size of the document can relate
to a text file or image kind of file.
The image on the bottom there is you don't
see that you don't see and it stands out because
it's an actual full on theater piece that
was about artificial intelligence. We wrote
a play and performed a play that was about
Alan Turing and John Sorel's debate about
artificial intelligence.
So we-we really ran a wide gamut of work from
screen based work to performance based work.
And the group of people that was listed prior,
and that group expanded and contracted with
other members and whatnot, and we came from
a range of backgrounds and a range of interests
and from programming to performance art and-and
whatnot. So we were all applying our skills
to do this, our projects over time.
So anyway the piece I'm going to focus on
is the "C5 Landscape Initiative" which was
a piece that we started thinking about in
2002 and it was really based on the notion
of doing expeditions and using GPS technology
to generate data and apply that data for different
purposes.
So the-the four projects that came out of
that are "The Analogous Landscape," "The Other
Path," "Perfect View," and "The C5 GPS Media
Player." They look like this. They don't look
like that.
[laughter]
So but if you are interested in reading these
are some people, good, they're worthwhile
checking out. Denis Cosgrove writes about
our perception of landscape and how that's
affected by culture. And Kevin Lynch is a
famous person talking about Cognitive Mapping
in the-the '50s. That's a famous book touchstone
for anybody thinking about urban mapping and
whatnot; The Image of the City.
Mitchell is a current writer talking about
network technologies and our experience of
space.
And Vi-Fu Tuan has been writing for decades
now about the-the nature of space and how
does it become place. They're more philosophical
texts, kind of interesting reading there.
So but here are what the projects look like,
right?
Here is "The Analogous Landscape," okay? And
where "The Analogous Landscape,"
[person sneezing]
as I say here predicted modeling based upon
analogous expeditions.
Our idea was that if we hiked some number
of mountains in the Ring of Fire around the
Pacific Rim, which were all volcanic mountains
and by that fact they have somewhat similar
topological features. If we hike those mountains
and record our hikes and take that data set
from say five mountains, can we predict how
to hike the sixth mountain? And that was our
starting notion.
And we first hiked Mt. Shasta which is in
Northern California about five hours north
of San Francisco. So we spent a weekend hiking
through the snow using crampons and the whole
bit because it's much safer, believe it or
not, to hike in the snow than it is in dry
rocks.
And-and along the way we were taking surveys.
We each had a Palm Pilot, the fancy technology
of the day, and on the Palm Pilot it had a
survey asking us what was our impression of
the landscape? How did we feel about, physically
feel about the hike so far? Had we seen anything
sublime yet? These kinds of questions.
And we would take the survey every half hour
and kind of that would kind of be a way of
estimating our progress or how we felt through
the hike and potentially after you get over
10,000 feet you become a different person.
[laughter]
So the survey- the survey would transform
a little bit, but.
And then secondly, geography does tap back
into – Guy Debord -- if anybody's read Guy
Debord and he was kinda thinking more about
urban situations but we're applying it to
a more natural situation.
And just to bump back this is when we achieved,
we-we conquered the summit so that's us sitting
up there. And the-the picture down there in
the right is a, is a digital reproduction
of Shasta using USGS data fed into a CNC machine
and making a little phone reproduction of
the mountain.
So in the exhibition the pieces look like
this. We have -- Shasta is on the right and
Fuji is on the left. So we got two mountains
conquered. Our goal was to go and go and go,
but you know the funding sources were like,
"Sure, right." [laughs] "Great idea."
It's a great idea and-and the-the piece functions
well in a gallery to get the concept across
and that's mostly what we were concerned with.
So what we've got are three foot by three
foot aluminum reproductions of the two mountains
that we did hike, Shasta and Fuji. And then
behind that are CGI models of the two mountains
rendered again from USGS data and the Japanese
equivalent of that.
And that is a video in the background that
has the mountain slowly rotating and with
a little red line showing how the, how we
hiked the mountains. And it kind of dissolves
between the two. Therefore you get to compare
the similarity or dissimilarity of the two
hikes.
So the goal was to have five of these or six
or ten. And it really would have been beautiful
to have a nice array of mountains, but because
of who we were which was very kind of ADD,
we gotta get the next project done and we
didn't have a lot of money, it was very expensive
to do what we did, we got that done and we're
pretty happy with that.
So an-another project within "The Landscape
Initiative" was "The Other Path." And in "The
Other Path" we're interested in taking a
data set and using that data set to see if
we could find similar topographies in the
world that would trigger similar psychological
experiences; in other words, a kind of a déjà
vu experience.
So one of our members went to China and traveled
the length of the Great Wall and used a GPS
device as they did so, and came back with
that data set. It was very heavy. [laughs]
So he had this big data set and we used that
to look for a similar location topographically,
topologically speaking in California, with
the notion that potentially we could find
a similar topography and therefore kind of
experience the Great Wall all over again.
And just in terms of computational interest
it presents a large data mining problem looking
at this big set of data and trying to find
similar qualities in this other set.
And in fact one of our group members is a
professor at UC San Diego so we had access
to some powerful computing, but it was still
a very insurmountable problem.
So we had to really, really reduce down what
we were looking for to looking at square kilometers
and measuring the low point and the high point,
and seeing what the average was between 'em
and if we found two kilometers, one being
in California and one in China that were similar,
then we'd move on to the next kilometer. And
if those are similar, we'd move on to the
next kilometer and so forth.
So it was a very kind of a crude search in
the end, but ultimately we did find a section
of California topography in Northern California,
ironically enough about 14 miles south of
Mt. Shasta where we started our first expedition.
And this topography was very much like the
section of land in China. Its, we went there
and hiked it and there's a fun story behind
that whole thing, but I'll skip that for the
moment.
Here's the installation; it's two pieces of
digitally etched glass that are about an inch
thick and four feet by four feet. The one
on the right over here is China and the one
on the left is obviously California.
So when you're in a gallery, you see these
two projections, you see the etched glass,
and within the projections you're seeing video
documentation from the expedition in China,
and then video doc-documentation from the
expedition in California, as well as kind
of a-a animated recreation of the search.
So as you look at the piece you get a sense
of the process of making the piece both in
terms of physical expeditions but also in
terms of the-the data mining that was going
on.
So one of our goals with this work was that
since we had been doing so much screen based
work in the late '90s and prior to this, and
one of the things that we noticed was there
was a lack of engagement by the public to
view, the work we were showing is typically
in galleries and museums and people are much,
seemed to be much more engaged by more physical,
sculptural kinds of work; more conventional
in an art world sense.
So we were trying to merge our interests in
data and technology with a more visceral experience
that you might expect to get from a museum.
So we, that's one of the reasons why we kinda
transitioned into this very kinda tactile,
visceral, sculptural work that's glass and
aluminum and whatnot.
And there's a lot of craftsmanship in there.
They were really beautiful pieces, they are.
The third piece is called "Perfect View" and
that's the one that I was kind of like the
project manager for, and we would kind of
do that. We'd chose various people to head
up these projects.
This is the one I was in charge of and what
it ended up being was a 13,000 mile trek around
the country guided by sublime sites supposedly,
sublime sites whose locations were given to
me by geocachers.
And geocaching is a hobby where people create
a treasure, they hide the treasure somewhere.
There-there are caches around here in the
city but most of them are out in rural areas.
So they hide these treasures and they record
the latitude and longitude coordinates for
them and put them up on a Website. And then
other geocachers, and there's thousands of
them in the country, go and look for the caches
for fun, for exercise, and it's a family thing,
it's all kinds of reasons to go.
But this was a large group of people that
I could approach and say, "Well give me latitude
and longitude coordinates for places that
you think are sublime." And that generated
a whole conversation online with this group
of people about, "What is sublimity and how
is it looked at in the, in the 18th and 19th
centuries versus today?" So it was kind of
a interesting dialog that happened out of
that.
But ultimately I was given 60 locations from
which I chose about 25. So the picture that
you're seeing on the left here is one of the
caches. Not a fabulous cache, just a plastic
box with some stuff in it. [chuckles]
But the real idea of-of geocaching is to get
to unusual place, locations that you wouldn't
necessarily go to.
So this happens to be in the northeast edge
of the lower peninsula of Michigan where there
is a river with a big oxbow turn, and you
have to hike through the woods to get there
and when you get there you're like above this
really, cool turn in the river that you wouldn't
know about really unless you were a geocacher
or you lived locally.
So these are some of the sites that I was
given; everywhere from you see Mississippi
and Texas and oddly enough very few in the
Southwest -- like nobody gave me the Grand
Canyon, but I would have skipped it anyway.
The obvious ones I ---
>>female in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Jack Toolin: What's that?
>>Jack Toolin: Yeah. [laughs]
So these are what the pieces look like for
a perfect view. They're tryptics; there are
three panels. The large one is photographic
documentation of the location. They're about
six, seven feet large, shot digitally and
then stitched together so you kind of have
a panoramic effect, but they're combined also
with satellite, aerial satellite imagery of
that location with a dot that tells you where
I was for the experience of sublimity when
I made the photograph.
And then the lower left image is a CGI recreation
of the topography using USGS data fed into
a 3D modeler, right?
So you're looking at the landscape in these
three different modes.
So hopefully it encourages people to reflect
on the new advent of-of imaging and experiencing
these topographies and what does it, how does
it affect our experience of nature, of these
topographies. Can we evaluate the topography
and come up with some kind of ideas about
what sublime is or not?
This is in Northern New York looking up at
the Adirondacks. It happens to be what's called
a virtual cache. There's no box there. You're
intended to go there and just experience the
site.
[pause]
This is in Kentucky. It's a natural arch.
It's a pretty cool piece 'cause it does have
all this natural beauty but down in the bottom
left corner it has Michael loves Debra, so.
[laughs] And that was, that was heartwarming.
[pause]
This is up in Maine --
and this is a video that I'll skip 'cause
it runs a little bit long, but it's a really
nice interview. It's up on YouTube. My channel
is Mad Chalet. But if you do a search for
Fatboy Slim, you might come across this and
this is one of the geocachers that just does
a really nice, gives a nice story about this
cache and Big Bend National Park that was
really an impressive cache 'cause it is out
in the middle of the desert and you hike about
a half mile, three-quarters of a mile through
the desert up into this nook and the-the climate
completely changes from dry desertous to cool,
wet waterfall with butterflies. [laughs] It's
just like, "Wow, where did this come from?"
And he's the one that directed me to that
cache and he's got a really nice story about
that.
And then that's the bike 'cause just you know
we all like bikes. Biking is cool. That's
the bike that did the-the dirty work getting
me around the country.
And then last but not least is "The C5 GPS
Media Player" which is an interface, online
interface for being able to, oh I'm not online.
[laughs] For being able to see the projects
"Analogous Landscape," "Other Path," and "Perfect
View" and see documentation and written notes
about locations, be able to load track logs
from different expeditions, and see geotagged
imagery that relates to these expeditions.
When this was done in 2004, before geotagging
was a common, as-as common as it is today,
so we wrote some software kind of make the-the
date/time code, timestamp in the photograph
correlate to the track log information so
it would poke these images up with their track
logs.
So, anyway you can play this interface. There's
I hope you go and explore it. It's at c5corp.com.
You'll be able to find this interface under
"The Landscape Initiative."
So anyway that's "The Landscape Initiative"
and that's a little bit about C5 and I'm happy
to answer questions about any of that stuff.
Yes.
>>male in audience: You said you had a funny
story about the California version of the
Great Wall.
>>Jack Toolin: Well a funny story about finding
the California version of The Great Wall is
that here we are with our GPS devices; everybody
had a GPS device, right? And pretty good GPS
device; pretty accurate. And the GPS device
telling you, "Go this way. Go that way." We
all think we know so much where it is. And
we thought, "People are gonna find this in
about an hour, maybe an hour, maybe an hour
and a half max." Right? And we, this happens
to be right next to the Pacific Coast Trail.
So we're up there hiking the Pacific Coast
Trail just havin' a great time and two hours
go by and then three hours go by, literally
four hours go by and we're like, we just finally
stop and pull out our maps and look at the
map, the paper map, and we find out, "Oh,
we've been hiking around the point we were
trying to get to." The point that our GPS
device kept on telling us, "Go here. Go here,"
was in the middle of the trail which was doing
this big arc and around-around a hill so the,
we're trying to get to the Wall of California
and it was up this very steep hill in the
middle of the trail; it was kind of circumventing
this hill [laughs]. So we'd been hiking around
and around and around and we needed to go
up, up, up. So it's just that one of those
ironies that here you've got all this technology,
you've looked at a map already, and then you
get there and it took four hours. We were
lucky to get back before it went dark. [laughs]
So that's that story.
Yeah.
>>male in audience: What's, is sublime, is
beautiful sublime, is [unintelligible sublime?
>>Jack Toolin: Right?
>>male in audience: Why'd you chose that word
and what did you learn about the word?
>>Jack Toolin: Yeah.
>>male in audience: from the experience?
>>Jack Toolin: Yeah. Yeah. Well that's a great
question.
One of the reasons I choose the word "sublime"
is I was interested in drawing parallels between
our time and the enlightenment, right?
And if you go back in the 18th century a lot
of writing and a lot of art was being done
about the sublime. And if you look at Kant
and a guy named Edwin Burke, their take on
the sublime was that, was maybe beautiful
but it was more than beautiful, it was terrifying.
It was something that was threatening. You
were feeling the force of nature which made
you so aware of your own mortality and forced
you to kind of transcend your rational capabilities
and move to another plane, right? So it was
that kind of a thing.
So that, and the reason I choose "sublime"
was to tap into that, but also it's a term
that kind of gets thrown around loosely and
often associated with landscape and loosely.
And today we do kind of think of it as something
very unusually beautiful, but it does have
this more threatening quality to it, and that
more threatening quality came into play in
several of the locations that I would visit,
which were banal in a lot of respects but
they had this challenging element to them
that was reminiscent of what Kant or Burke
might have been writing about.
But ultimately what sublime is is we pretty
much can guess, it's very subjective, right?
So I'm in the Ozark Mountains and somebody
tells me to go to Hocksville Crag 'cause it's
sublime and I go way out of my way. The ride
to get there was sublime [laughs] going through
the woods and getting there and then here's
a rock that's looking over trees in a valley
and it was like, "Okay."
But if you'd just been to Zion National Park
two weeks beforehand where you're like on
top of this rock and the canyons are just
like blow you away kind of quality, it was
like you wanted to tell the person to go to
Zion National Park. [laughs] 'Cause like so,
but everybody's got their-their sense of what
sublime is.
So somebody else sent me into a public park
in the middle of Nebraska; a little stand
of trees in between baseball fields and basketball
courts and here's this little stand of trees
with some small rocks in there --
[laughter]
So it was very intimate whole different thing.
So yeah, sublime is hard to put your finger
on and everybody depending on what your context
is and what your background and what you're
bringing to is it's very subjective.
So it really wasn't to try to do-do a scientific
analysis of sublimity, but to use that as
a, as a guide for me to go around the country
and apply these technologies to looking at
topography and landscape.
So I'm also doing what we now call social
networking and sourcing information from a
cloud and finding locations to go and visit.
So it was just a way to interact with people
and get this series of way points that I wouldn't
have been able to get any other way, if that
makes sense.
[pause]
Yeah.
>>male in audience: [unintelligible] What
did you do experientially [unintelligible}?
>>Jack Toolin: The survey? [laughs] But sitting
on the Palm Pilots in a box somewhere. We
didn't really like process it, but we exhibited
as you, that photograph has those Palm Pilots
there and each one would have showed different
answers like the one that you see most closely
in that picture is a tree. So that was one
of the aspects of the survey was like a draw
a picture of what you see in front of you.
So somebody drew a tree.
But those would be displayed and have various
questions from the survey so you can kinda
get a sense of what the emotional response
was to that hike.
[pause]
>>male in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Jack Toolin: Yeah. Well I think it would
be interesting. I don't know about useful,
but it would be interesting. Yeah.
[pause]
>>voice in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Jack Toolin: An-an emotional mountain?
>>Jack Toolin: [laughs] That would be cool.
That's a good name for it too, The Emotion
-- [laughs]
Yeah, one of the things about C5 was that
we were always kind of looking towards the
next thing. So this project we really could
have spent many years on it. Just on one of
them doing "The Analogous Landscape" and hiking
the mountains around the Pacific Rim. That
could have been a really, a long undertaking.
But because of, I don't know, the personalities
involved in the collaboration, we're just
antsy and moving on. So once we kind of got
the concept across in these pieces, we were
already on to doing our next project was called
"Quest for Success" which was another GPS
kind of game interactivity kind of thing that
took place in San Jose.
So -- and before you knew it, we dissolved
in 2007 so that these projects kind of, they
were at that standstill. So --
And then individually we've kind of gone on
and worked in various modes, some of us doing
located media.
[pause]
>>female in audience: I just am wondering
how that sublime location project that you
undertook, was it ever part of the C5 Group?
>>Jack Toolin: Yeah.
>>female in audience: So-so you came up with
the idea together, but you were the one to
execute it?
>>Jack Toolin: Yeah, I-I executed most of
it. And that happened to be true for a lot
of the projects, but we were all involved
in various aspects of the projects.
We all went on the hikes and somebody else's
modeling created CGI imagery for the-the tryptics
that you saw. I mean I-I did the, I spent
the two months traveling around the country
photographing places and actually built the
tryptics.
But I mean the idea for it and some of the
work that went into it was, it was a collaborative
thing that made it happen; the discussions
that we had. And there was actually some really
kinda funny stories how we got to doing expeditions
and all that. We got there because of alcohol
basically. [chuckles]
[laughter]
There's a, a lot of fun there.
But anyway I feel like I'm eating up, eating
into time here.
>>Scott Draves: You have a couple minutes
for more questions.
>>Jack Toolin: Okay.
Yeah.
>>male in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Jack Toolin: Ah, you know I don't know.
I don't how their, what are they doing with
geocaching --
>>male in audience: Basically [unintelligible]
>>Jack Toolin: Yeah. Yeah.
>>male in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Jack Toolin: Right.
>>male in audience: And then there's like
this whole gaming culture around it [unintelligible]
>>Jack Toolin: But that sounds like that's
much more geared towards urban, suburban kind
of area, yeah?
>>male in audience: Yeah.
>>Jack Toolin: At least with what you're describing
--
>>male in audience: Yeah.
>>Jack Toolin: in terms of cache being --
>>male in audience: Yeah. Yeah.
>>Jack Toolin: You know I think that the people
who-who-who are into geocaching are at least
as much into hiking and being out in nature.
Although li-like I said there are caches in
Manhattan, in urban areas too.
So well one of the funny things about geocaching
is that you're using this technology to get
very close to the cache and once you're very
close to the cache, it's gets increasingly
harder to find it 'cause the-the GPS only
has about 15 feet of accuracy and it depends
on you moving. And once you get within 15
feet your tendency is to stop and say, --
>>female in audience: There's no one who says,
"Hotter, hotter, colder, colder?"
>>Jack Toolin: Nobody does that. [laughs]
[laughter]
So you're looking around and chances are the
thing is right there, Scott's got it and,
but you spend 45 minutes looking for Scott
'cause you can't find it, but this is one
of those ironic things about --
>>Scott Draves: We have time for one more
question.
[pause]
>>female in audience: What's next?
>>Jack Toolin: Well I've been working on photographic
projects; a project called "White Collar"
that actually has, that focuses on middle
aged white men, businessmen who are faced
with the transitions happening in global economics
and-and I'm tryin', I am capturing kind of
the psychological states possibly that they're
experiencing.
And so I have a body of work that's about
that specifically. I've done a lot of work
about economics over the years and that work
is transitioning into mapping people's commutes
and thinking about how lifestyles are related
to workspace and what that transition is between
life, home life and work; so there's a project
that has to do with mapping commutes and kind
of in a psychogeographic way.
I mean what's your experience of your commute?
And what do you think you're passing through
when you pass through Jersey City? What do
you think it is? And then, and then drawing
up data that talks about what it is. What
is the demographic and what is the economic
situation of that town? As opposed to what
your perception of it is, right?
So that's what I'm working on.
>>Scott Draves: Good. Thank you very much.
>>Jack Toolin: Yep.
[applause]
>>Scott Draves: Okay, that's the end of our
program this evening. I'd like to also encourage
you to come to our-our future lectures.
So on Friday, October 1st we have Rachel Armstrong
and Mitchell Jaochim speaking about their
art and closing up on Thursday, October 21st,
we have Marina Zurkow and our own Andrew Senior
and Sandra Cordero speaking about their pieces.
So thanks again for coming and I hope to see
you all on Friday the 1st.
Good night.
[applause]